Alice, need we remind you
how you got your job?
[You Sexy Thing
by Hot Chocolate]
♪ ♪
[knock at door]
Yello.
Hey, uh, what's up, player?
I'm Ice Holmvik.
I'm here for an orientation.
Oh, that's a--
that's an unusual name.
What's the significance
to that, Ice?
I used to swim,
but then I started rhyming,
and my rhymes were so cold
that the water froze.
Hence, Ice Holmvik.
Oh, that's--I
love--I love rap.
I love rap too.
I'm also into hip-hop fashion.
- You know, like--
- Right.
This guy, Kanye, is like,
starting to really
come up and change the game,
so I started a denim line.
Check that.
It's called, "Rawegian."
I don't really have them
steady sagging right now,
but usually I do.
But since I'm at work,
I pull them up out of respect.
George: I appreciate that.
I'll tell you what.
If you wear slacks tomorrow,
I'll cut you some slack today.
- That's what's up.
- All right, well,
orientation's in about ten
minutes--conference room.
- That's what's up.
- Thank you, buddy.
- All right, Ice.
This is gonna be fun, buddy.
(Blake)
[laughing]
What the hell are
you guys doing here?
You're supposed
to be in class.
(Blake)
You get it, bro.
It's, like, a financial crisis
we're going through.
- Yeah.
- Recession, college loans,
- the bailouts--
- Bailouts, yep.
- So you know, we bailed out.
Barack Obama!
You dropped out of college?
Yeah, as real bosses do.
Bill Gates,
the child from Facebook.
Hey, guess what, guys. It's
Steve Jobs not Steve College.
- That's funny.
- 'Cause I'm kind
of gonna be the office
funny guy around here.
I feel like that's my vibe.
That's my calling.
That's my truth.
Okay, so should we clock
in or something?
No, we definitely
shouldn't clock in, okay?
I should clock in,
because this is my job
and you don't belong here.
This is where I am going
to turn over a new leaf
and become the man I was
supposed to be, Ice Holmvik.
I will not call you that.
I will never, ever
call you Ice Holmvik.
- This is--yes, you will.
- Oh, Ders, check it out.
- Ice is what I'm called.
- Yeah, but check it out.
(Anders)
Dude, is that--
is that Lacey Jams?
Yes, like, 100%.
That's her, man.
Don't look up. Don't look.
Be cool. Be cool.
Does that mean that
that dude right there is--
the dude--the mole--
the mole man?
If that's him,
I bow to thee,
because he's got a
huge sausage, right?
And she derbs it all
the way up to this mole
- that he's got on the base--
- It's true, dude.
She's not thro' yet,
but she's a prospect.
She's like the Derrick Rose
of deep throat, dude.
- Yeah.
Oh, is that, like,
an Internet thing?
Ugh, yuck.
Oh, Adam, you are still taking
a hard stance on the Internet.
Dude, it is 2008.
Don't be 2000-late, okay?
The Internet and computers
are for dweebs and nerds.
You got to get
on there, dude.
It's, like, a lot of
amazing porno on there.
- Yeah.
- This Internet porno fade--
that's gonna--it's gonna fade
away because porno stars
are on the covers of DVDs
and the covers of VHS tapes.
Haha, okay, cool dudes,
I want all new recruits in
the conference room right now.
Let's do this. Come on.